good evening everyone or good afternoon
or good morning depending on where
you're joining us from here around the
globe welcome thank you for joining us
for this webinar with simply learn
America's president ray Reich skills
acquisition versus talent acquisition
how to use employee training to save on
recruiting costs now talent acquisition
is one way to get critical skills in
house but recruiting is expensive and it
can take a long time and even if you do
find a candidate well you can't be sure
they're necessarily going to fit your
culture and stick around that's why
focusing on skills acquisition among
your existing employees may be a more
cost-effective solution for you and lead
to greater employee retention in the
long run now ray Reich is the president
of simply learn America's and he's here
to share recent research and insight
into how companies are using training to
stay ahead of the curve if you're not
familiar with Ray he's been providing
strategic leadership with multiple
high-growth companies including a Colo
hire mojo Netscape GE QRS market first
and a cruet it's got an extensive
background in high technology and human
resources and he's here to share his
unique insights into both talent
acquisition and employee training and
the benefits thereof but before we start
I want to make sure that everybody's
hearing this ok and set some
expectations for how everything is going
to run so first thing is pleased if you
would just take a look at your dashboard
and see if you can't find that questions
field there a little questions module
for you to ask things of us let's go
ahead and test that out if you would go
ahead and type in there and just say
hello I wish Ray well and let him know
that you're looking forward to hearing
what he's got to say maybe tell us where
you're joining us from
and what's the weather like where you're
joining us from right now I'm on the
west coast of California and it's about
eight thirty at night and it's been a
really incredibly lovely day but I want
to make sure that my audio is going out
to all of you who have joined us so go
ahead and drop something in there and
and let us know again in the questions
module not in the chat box but in the
questions module raised presentations
going to run about 40 minutes and as as
he moves through that this question
module is going to be your best friend
if there's something that you would like
more clarification on if you want ray to
go back and revisit a slide or go into a
little deeper on a particular point this
is where you can drop that in as we're
moving forward and at the end of the
actual presentation we will loop back
around and do a complete Q&A from end to
end try to cover everybody's questions I
see Praveen says hello from hyderabad
india i hope i pronounced that right and
that's good to know that you all are
able to hear us okay sometimes
GoToWebinar it can be a little tricky
that way and I'm just talking to myself
let's see now if you hear something
really tremendous and you want to share
it by the way on your social channels of
course please do feel free to do so go
ahead and tweet any insights or anything
that you get out of this to your Twitter
your Facebook your LinkedIn or what have
you use the hashtag SL webinars if you
like and that way your friends and your
colleagues will see all the cool stuff
your list your learning and they'll get
jealous and maybe they'll join us next
time raji it has joined us from chennai
and the weather is great sunny and hot
that's the way I like it too I am a
lizard and I prefer the warm weather to
the cold weather so I'm a little bit
jealous all right listen that's all you
need to know from me will have a
presentation for 40 minutes or so use
that questions module to ask your
questions as we move through and after
about 40 minutes of presentation will
loop around and we'll do all that Q&A
that I'm going to step back out of the
way and i'm going to let ray tech take
over ray thank you for joining us yeah
thank you very much can you hear me okay
absolutely it's all yours my friend okay
thank you very much and thank you very
much to the audience today so i did this
webinar in presentation a few weeks ago
for a audience in the United States and
we received very very high marks for the
interest level and more importantly we
had several follow-up conversations to
learn more of a not companies toya
skills acquisition strategy within their
organization so on Priyanka from our
marketing team and bang one asked if I
would go ahead and do this presentation
for a more global audience specifically
today doing it for the audience
primarily out of India so thank you very
much for joining us so I'm going to move
on and talk a little bit about the
agenda here and really as we go through
this it kind of has been built over 30
years of my career I said the first 10
years at the GE company and I always
felt very very privileged and honored to
have an organization that invested so
much in my own development through
training and skills acquisition and then
over the last 20 years like the night
here in Silicon Valley and sometimes
moving so fast in the startup world that
we kind of step back though I need five
more people who understand angularjs or
I need eight people to understand
Microsoft reserve because we're trying
to move so fast often we actually will
hire them for a Predator versus Tiffani
back and saying how do I really ensure
that my employees I have are going to be
here two years five years down the road
so that's what really created this
agenda so first of all a lot of
organizations really don't understand
the total cost of talent acquisition
they think about I and I internal
recruiter and you post something on the
job board like an occurring and I go
through maybe an external recruiter for
certain hard to fill jobs but they don't
really understand that total cost of
thai language we're going to talk a lot
more about that the cost of attrition
the cost of productivity ramps etc
simply have to talk more
valve is how actually investing money in
training to actually save your
organization so when that CFO that why
would I invest $300,000 between those
people like why would we waste three
million dollars by not training those
people so we'll talk a little bit about
that one of the things is really
important in a high growth economy and
Indians experience that for many years
we've experienced that in Silicon Valley
for many many years it's how do we
really get our best and brightest to be
here three years four years five years
out because the constant replacing our a
player's is very high how do we actually
enhance our employer brand especially
with the younger generation of the
length the Millennials they really want
to understand how is that company going
to invest me after I take a job so that
part of your employer branding is
critical talk a little bit of a value
boost profitability we give you a kind
of a almost a skills acquisition for
dummies type approach at six steps way
to start so now I'm going to be right
into the webinar itself what things
would like you to think about is
something that Paul's have already said
and you can read it here but I think
this goes to a famous saying that a lot
of us need to think about and a CFO once
asked me this it's like but what if we
invest all this money in the train that
you want and our employees leaf and I
kind of looked at them and I said what
if we don't invest in them and they stay
so it's a different way to think about
investing our most important asset
employees is going to directly impact
business productivity now the CEO of 18
p just recently came out and said put
over 300,000 employees around the world
for those employees who don't invest at
least 5 10 hours a week learning online
they will obsolete themselves with
technology and the World Economic Forum
just came out with a very interesting
research report about four months ago
and they said the sixty-five percent of
our children who are entering primary
school now
when they take their first job after
graduating from University sixty-five
percent of those jobs don't even exist
today so think about that sixty-five
percent of the jobs they killed in
primary school today will first take
don't even exist today that just tells
you a little bit about the pace with
which the global economy is moving and
the job market itself in fact if you
look at the next slide I think you'd be
pretty sharp just last year if you look
at some of the high-growth position
weary of the largest skill gaps on a
global basis with 28 million jobs across
mobile app development cloud computing
Big Data project management process
manager like agile scrum and almost
thirty percent of those jobs nine
million went unfilled for greater than
90 days so if you think about that if
you've got business initiative new
projects customer projects which are
funding on a professional services basis
if you can't fill those jobs with excuse
me external candidates what are we going
to do and we're here today to tell you
that one of the best places to be able
to attract these skills both your
current employee base with the skills
acquisition strategy so they move from
here but once again think about that
almost one-third of all emerging
technology and process jobs went
unfilled for greater than 90 days last
year now women's invention is we're
going to talk about the total cost of
talent acquisition so one of the
companies I had a good fortune of Vernon
over the last few years was in the
talent acquisition space using software
to really identify who are the best
candidates for particular jobs but one
of the things I started to realize it
cost a lot more to hire someone than
just what you pay for recruiting so of
course you know with that if you use
continues to recruiters here in the
states you can pay twenty twenty-five
percent of person
tejas I or someone but if you really
start looking at the total cost lost
productivity of a nutrition some of
leaving your company the length of the
time that job is open the three to six
months to ramp a new employee to for
productivity a reason sure they came out
this has the total cost to replace this
year hard to fill role and being from
1.5 x 22 x at the annual salary so think
about that if you have someone making
the equivalent of 32,000 US dollars in
india that actual turning cost we fill
that position can be anywhere from 45
thousand to 60,000 US dollars
significantly more than twenty percent
of the first year salary in fact another
recent report by the person group and
Deloitte it cost about four thousand US
dollars to fill an average white collar
position VI tus so as you can see it's a
lot more than just the cost of recruiter
to fill position what are some of those
things you have to think about in fact
we would highly recommend that you
really take a total survey of what it
costs you to hire eternity unemployed
first of all a lot of the advertising
you need an whether that's you know just
posting on a job or and I like the
courier indeed on paying the recruiters
getting it recruiters wrapped doing
background checks etc but then you've
got that onboarding that rent of
productivity and that's where a lot of
companies really don't calculate that
cost because that's not a direct hard
costs but it's a fast productivity loss
cost but we ask you and your finance
department to really try to understand
how much productivity to wheel is now
I'm certain roles like a sales role it's
really easy if you've got a sales
position open for three months and
another three months to wrap a new
employee that's really amazing in a I
can services professional services
organization at a certain billing rate
if you've got an empty position or the
persons on the once they get ramped
there on the bench for
Ford Center time just as easy to
calculate that and then also one of the
other things is ruins our vendor says
what's the cost of lost engagement once
again then employee who is not working
at Israel his or her utmost potential
they're kind of taking a little bit of
trying to go out and look at the job
boards and seek another job and it takes
a little bit more time off to go to the
interviews you don't feel that they're
being invested by your organization and
then the real cost of a talent
acquisition strategy versus the skills
acquisition strategy can be viewed in
this last data point thirty three
percent of senior or hard to fill
positions that are filled with an
external kenneth using recruiting upon
acquisition will leave within the first
six months and apartment told me a
saying that i really never forgot that
is we hire people for what they are they
are a Java developer they are a dupe
architect so we hire them for what they
are and we fire them for who they are
because they don't share the company
values or they don't align with the
personality attributes of our
organization so if you have great
employees who already understanding your
business fit into your culture share
your values it's a much more prudent
investment to invest in during the skill
gap way up skilling and reselling them
course going to the outside world and
just trying to hire that talent from the
outside now the other thing to think
about and this actually comes from the
bursa group also if an employee's value
accelerates a nonlinear model as they
have more and more time in your
organization in fact that first 12 to 18
months that's the investment zone that's
when you acquire them you on board them
you train them to not really providing a
positive return on investment yet to the
organization as measured by output
it's only after we get that return zone
which is often 18-24 months al so you
start seeing that exponential growth and
return on investment of that down
acquisition dollar so whatever we can do
to retain an employee for 24 36 48
months they're going to have much and
add much more economic value to an
organization your skin you can read love
it more about this and the version
report of 2013 so to summarize on our
training investment save your money
versus count acquisition remember that
that 1.5 to 2 x of annual salary is what
it's really going to cost you in direct
costs and productivity cost for those
hard to fill ite emerging technology
jobs so let's talk a little bit more
about employee retention in fact you can
read these bullet points i'm not going
to read it to you but there is a
recently survey done by the corporate
executive board and a data point jumped
out at me that i wanted to share today
and that is eighty-nine percent of
people who view their organizations as
investing and their career development
through training are more likely to stay
at that company eighty-nine percent so
that's a huge number of why you want
invest in skills acquisition strategy
the other thing you want to think about
is forty percent of employees who
received poor training in their first
year aren't much more likely to leave
their positions so there's a lot of data
points that so that's your employees and
they won't vest back in you and and
today's fast-growing the emerging
technology world and more and more than
Millennials coming to work force this is
another thing that really jumped out of
me and that was an eighth ice.com salary
indices on the leading and job warts on
posting fights for the tech industry to
third
IT workers or digital workers believe
they could find a better job in less
than six days if they only took the time
to look so what we want to do as an
organization is by investing in a
skilled requisition on a continuous
process with our employees not even to
make them for day think they want to
look for a different job let's keep them
fully engaged the other thing and maybe
a little more in United States and India
but we've created a real issue with
Millennials coming out of university
today and that is for the 118 years the
baby boomer generation that done
everything for their kids from what
primary school should go to to a high
school to driving into all the events to
all their programs so a lot of these
Millennials really aren't used to I
gotta figure it out for myself the only
way I'm going to get ahead is by working
harder than the next person so they now
believe its management job in the
workforce to provide them with
accelerated development opportunities I
don't know how many times over the last
couple years but that millennial who's
worked six nine months in there the
existing role will come to me and say
well I think I'm ready to be a director
now now once again it's not like that in
all parts of the world and it's
definitely not like that avenia yet but
we're certainly seeing a much more
entitled workforce in their 20s and they
are going to demand that we have an
organization continue to invest to
upskill them so even though they may be
more valuable to the outside world but
definitely more valuable to you a little
bit more data this is from Shirin and
Shirin is a society for human resource
resource professionals and it just is
more data out there that says 42 s
almost one-half of employees or a rating
job training is very important on the
125 scale very important being the
highest but only a quarter twenty five
percent are satisfied with the amount of
change or refusing is easy
this match between expectations of
getting great training and what they're
actually receiving today so just more
data to say more you invest your
employees that better serve you're going
to be now the other thing as global
marketplace is growing so fast one of
the things we want to always think about
is how do i enhance my employer grant
employer brands of the combination of
major things but one of those things is
if you get the reputation for hiring
only great people out of university but
also investing with applied learning on
the job training opportunities people
will start fought into your organization
could have a much higher level of
employee engagement and people start
thinking about their career path not
outside of your organization but their
career paths and concert with the
continuous learning journey with dania
organization giving it's really
interesting in this came from another
person report is only about fifty
percent of employees today would
recommend to their friends and
colleagues that their company is a
destination workplace so anything that
we can do by investing in training and
helping our employees acquire skills and
welcomes achieve their career goals it's
going to have a direct result on your
employee brand employee engagement chip
I'm going to take a break Gary see if we
have any questions yet
let's take a quick look here one of the
comments is you mentioned two-thirds of
workers think that they can find a
better job in less than 90 days does
that square with that 90 ish day period
that you quoted for filling skilled hard
to fill positions in other words are
those two thirds of workers right that
make it run out and find a job in that
period of time or are they being overly
optimistic about the marketability of
their skills no in fact those two data
points are in direct forming so let me
explain that so I'm a iOS developer and
I I know if I go out there's a million
iOS jobs right now posted on web sites
but I could get a job in less than 60
days on the flip side as an employer I'm
fighting a million other companies to
hire iOS developers so for me to get my
job opportunity in front of a potential
employee is very hard because there's so
much noise so the reason it takes you
longer than 90 days to fill the job is
because I'm competing against thousands
if not hundreds of thousands of other
companies so there's a direct
correlation to I at the candidate can
get a job quickly but I is the employer
are going to have a harder time finding
those hard to fill positions where
there's more demand for that job than
areas Canada supply ship any other right
now um let's do let's do one more before
you jump back in yeah so someone here is
saying that you know if I'm a team
leader and I understand the value of
providing training to my people how do i
get management focused on that
importance of that training I presume
that means people up the food chain from
them who might have to sign off on the
acquisition and implementation of a
training program how can a team leader
get upper management or c-suite by an
to the value of the training so that
they can bring it to their teens well
that question is going to go right to
step five of the sixth step hence i'm
going to give you and that is how do you
really measure the results of your
training investments so i'm going to
cover that little bit chip but let me
just say that if you're measuring return
on the resume training by how many
employees special training you're not
going to get executive support it's how
do you measure the impact on the job of
the competencies and skills required
during that training i'll talk more
about that in about ten minutes that's a
great question because you need to
determine how do I measure the
productivity of my function let's say
that is a developer it might be what's
the bug rate in the code that I did
after twenty first before or maybe it's
investing in agile scrum methodology and
today you can actually deliver twenty
percent more feature function that's
relevant in the same time than it took
four or five months ago we need to think
about how you made the productivity of
your funky and do a benchmark before you
invest into me and then later afterwards
can see if you're very little return on
investment so cheap resume with
questions right now I think I'm going
just move forward with plain absolutely
okay so here is some more data and once
again to the person that's a question
how do I can events my leadership that I
need to invest in training you're going
to have access to this presentation
after the webinar today and we've also
actually written a white paper on skills
acquisition include of this data coming
from multiple credible sources is
irrefutable so the things you're seeing
here is things like 2252 percent more
productive IBM recently conducted a
survey of project performance
they measure the percent of projects
that were delivered on time before they
invested in PMP training for their
project managers and afterwards and what
IBM found was they had an eighty-four
percent increase and projects being
delivered on time when they were ran by
a PMP PMI certified project manager
versus without a PMP PMI certified
project manager and that is a 2013
report on IBM so my recommendation to
everyone on the phone is the more you
can use data points that are validated
by independent third parties of the
return on investment for training the
quicker you're going to get your
executive of your department to CFO to
buy into that so let's give that six
step idea of how to implement a skilled
acquisition strategy so the first thing
and I think this is critical and also
help senior executives say you know what
you're right we do need to invest in
training and having a skilled
acquisition strategy how can you
benchmark where do you have skill gaps
today now a lot of times you might know
that you have a new project that's with
a big client you need 28 on
cybersecurity people and you want to get
fixed people who are on the bench so
sometimes it's really easy now the other
thing we would recommend is how do you
do a pre-assessment one pre-assessment
might be look at external certification
exams and have employees actually go and
try to get that certification and
identify whether it is or is not a
skills gap you might go to do it too
simple simple survey techniques maybe
you were looking for someone who really
understand social media marketing and
there is organizations like om CP which
is one of the world's leading digital
marketing certification providers that
you can actually do a quick assessment
through a series of quizzes to see where
there's efficiencies so first of all is
make sure that you do some type of skill
gaps analysis
and offer first of all look at what
guilt sets my current organization can
best be enhanced and up skilled to
achieve that one might being you have
java developers if you have java
developers were you doing a huge new UI
UX project they are probably best
position to help I do you knew us
development using angularjs so always
look at kind of career pathing and then
most tangential skills that can be
enhanced through of scaling and
rescaling step 2 what are those goals
for training and this is where as that
team lead don't just talk about employee
engagement employee retention etc what
are the specific key performance
indicators that you can measure before
and after training so really align your
training and the skills achieved to your
strategic business objectives one of the
easy things today most organizations
especially industrial companies if
they're going through digital
transformation initiatives so how do you
equate investing in cloud developers or
proud architects into your digital
transformation measurements so the more
you can align it to the strategic
objective the better now what are the
other ways that we believe that a lot of
companies are assessing the nature
skills assessment is through external
certifications an example might be a I
just implemented salesforce com and I
need 52 developers for the poor calm
develop environment well that means i
need to get people who are self horse
developer category 1 certified so one of
the things you might want to think about
is certification is a great cult the
other thing that we found is just having
a common language of a new conversion
technology for businesses can be of
great value we had one technology
company that recently said and we
weren't all 5,000 of all marketers
around the world to have one common
language of digital marketing so when
someone talks about conversion
optimization here you know that means
whether the SEO resource create paid
search resource / social media marketing
resource so train cannot always be a
quantitative it can be more of a
qualitative such as developing that
common language of business and a
particular function so third step if you
want to implement a continuous in robust
learning program really choose the right
training partner and one of the things
that we found is no one training
delivery model is going to reach every
employer letter type what does it mean
so just going to Luke and getting great
developer training from MIT may not be
the liaison developers earn some
developers may learn with more of an
instructor-led with labs and applied
learning opportunities so really look at
training partners that can provide
different training delivery models that
address the largest number of
constituents in your organization the
other thing that's really important with
training is don't just provide a
monologue you're listening to these 18
hours of training and do a couple
projects and you'll be fine the more you
can actually provide applied learning
opportunity specific to your business
the better an example maybe you're going
to be teaching people on about agile
scrum then what we would recommend is
have a simulation that allows you to
have both developers and product
managers actually looking at user
stories and how would they point those
and then see how the product manager use
story points versus the product
development resource so once again
choosing the right training for it to
provide you a lot of best practices and
different ways to reach forge your
target audience for your company step
number four and this is critical and
this is where that senior executive
support is going to be so important and
that is would it be incentives for
employees who are working 40 50 hours a
week who don't have time
take one app three hours of training why
are they going to do it well number one
if a key executive says this is critical
to your organization because we're going
to make sure that we have the widest
employee engagement on career paths
opportunity of any of our competitors
what are going to do that through a
continuous learning opportunity or as in
Microsoft's case which is a lot of our
clients excuse me I'm going to take the
ticket warrior the chief marketing
officer actually created a training
initiative that resulted in a internal
digital marketing certification and
every marketing leader around the world
knew that they needed to promote people
first to receive the Microsoft digital
marketing certification so let's get an
example where there was a huge incentive
for students completing that training
even things like gamification and badges
for the people who come complete the
training first for the people who do the
applied learning and have projects that
they applied with peer reviews to get
the highest peer review scores but
there's many different ways even things
like gift cards that five dollars
durable car just rewarding people for
completing self-directed learning all
those can be a great way to build a
culture of continuous learning and
employees investing in your own career
growth now once again this is a little
bit more of a us-centric flight but one
planes countries states provinces why
tax advantages and corporate incentives
for investing an employee training so
for your local jurisdiction the ignore
any of those tax credits or incentives
for investing in your employees through
training initiatives we talked a lot
about measuring trend results and this
goes back to the question that was asked
earlier chip so number one you do want
to see what the learner engagement
satisfaction wise but those are just
level one measurements of return to
Odessa for training but good do at Net
Promoter Score see how many applicants
you have for the train that you deliver
internally versus how many people are
more passionate about it or let
detractors the second thing is how did
someone what do they really learn and
what's their ability to actually apply
that so one of the things we would say
for every training program you ever
implement your organization make sure
there's a final assessment it's a little
bit like you went to school set through
10 weeks of trade up classes and never
had a test how would you ever prove that
you retained and understand curriculum
same thing in corporate training you
have internal assessments or align your
train to extra certifications where they
actually have to take day camps and then
the third thing you want to do is make
sure that when they go back when your
employer employee goes back on the job
come are we going to measure that
they're actually applying what they
learned on the job the best way to do
that is number one with objectives that
I specifically to apply in your project
and of course having key performance
educators indicators and [ __ ] boards
before in post training emitting the
last thing is we look at this as a
multi-year return on investment analysis
can that is for the employees who took
the training and scored the highest or
we're best able to improve their
performance reviews year-over-year look
at those people two three four five
years out and start collecting data on
board in life directors or senior
directors or VPS come from as it relates
to the training initiatives they
participated in and how they did and
then step six is really about make sure
you have a culture of promote from
within and that inference and provides
opportunities for that continuous Bernie
culture one of the ways to do that is as
you do success succession planning
across every category go and put those
two or three key people for that role
but
what type of training they would like
tell you like to enhance their skill set
and just always create that culture of a
continuous learning environment the
other thing that you want to do is help
guide your work force with which new
skill they should develop so one of the
things you might say is you know we're
looking at emerging technologies we
really want to invest in a big data
initiative over the next 12 to 18 months
we'd like people to step up and
volunteer to go and spend X hours per
week on enhancing their web l.a skills
digital analytics and big data maybe
it's a Duke training this giving
examples the more you can incense and
that people think 12 18 24 month long
can provide them the infrastructure in
the platform for self-directed
self-selected training the better off
you'll be in the long term so that I'm
going to wrap up one things I would like
to say and what we found a lot of my I'm
a front line manager I don't really have
a very strong training development or
learning department what do you expect
to me how am I going to train my
employees well number one there's always
a strategic option of outsourcing train
and out forcing takes many different
shapes that can be just finding a great
on elearning aggregation or marketplace
and providing a hundred dollars per
month or two hundred dollars per year
spice and for people to take their
learning courses and today's kind of
online learning whether than elearning
or instructor-led live virtual
classrooms employees have the
opportunity to take training before they
come to work after work on weekend
provide them every talk opportunity to
take their free time and apply it
towards better yourselves and the other
thing about any training to trying never
to invest a dollar and training unless
there's an applied learning on the job
opportunity to immediately come apply
what they learn in class online to the
real world projects in fact one of those
I saw the other day with seven
five percent of people who get trained
to not apply what they learn in training
for six months or more and you can
probably imagine the efficacy and
ability to recall that if you're not
applying any photon receive skills for
six months a traitor so with that chip
I'm going to turn it back over to you
and I can see if there's any last minute
questions and then I'll do a quick
summary in hand all right there are
there a few questions here cued up and
we've still got some time before the end
of our allotted time slot before we do
that though if you don't mind and if
everybody who's joined us doesn't mind
I'm going to take care of what I like to
call my contractually obligated screen
take over I'm going to launch a little
Paul here really quickly and take over
your screen there ray so I've done that
and I've got a pull up on the screen
just to let you all know this this
webinar of course is free to anyone to
join us and we're happy to have you here
it's public facing webinar you don't
have to already be a client or a student
with simply learn but we do think it's
important for you to know that there are
a lot of trainings that we in fact can
provide for your teams we provide
training across a variety of disciplines
as a business and technology training
provider 400 web-based training courses
in our system across a wide spectrum of
skill sets including things you know
like digital marketing and project
management and programming and so forth
and these courses are accredited by more
than 40 30 third-party certifying bodies
like Prince 2pm IMCP the open group and
so forth our trainings are specifically
designed to prepare your teams for those
certification exams from those
third-party providers based on the very
latest bodies of knowledge that those
organizations require all of these
courses are designed
presented by our faculty of experienced
professional trainers so when your folks
when your teams when your employees and
your team members they join these
training programs they get structured
courses they get information and
resources hands-on practical experience
some cases they get lab exercises and
simulation exams access to platforms
where they get software for running
experiments and doing practice projects
and more if you'd like to know more
about what we can offer you tick the
appropriate box and we will have
somebody get in touch with you to answer
all your questions and help set a plan
that's appropriate for your goals for
your team all right I'm going to go
ahead and close that thanks for
indulging me make that go away and Ray
it'll revert back to your screen here
real quickly I think come on GoToWebinar
catch up with me there we go so we're
seeing your Thank You screen and and
folks have that contact information
showing there as well okay let's take a
look at questions and let's scroll back
here so this goes to needs assessment
question is I imagine i need to do needs
assessment across my team to establish
who needs what kind of training the most
do you have any best practice tips for
me to acular accurately establish the
training my team needs and that i should
invest in ray are you with me oh I am so
I three years another good all right
sorry my new button get stuck no problem
what is now it's very easy with today's
survey technology just look at the key
projects you have going on within your
function and the requisite skills that
you believe are needed to execute those
projects and do a survey of your
employees that will be responsible for
that and that's them for a
self-assessment on where their skills
range on a one-to-five scale from don't
need it i really need skills to i have
it like an expert at that and we do it
skills inventory just with using sir
tools there's one very simple do you can
do yourself number two as I mentioned
earlier look at third party
certifications that can quantitatively
determine whether you do or do not have
the requisite skills within your current
team so let's say that is Salesforce
administration skills a real easy one
right go ahead and have them apply and
take the Salesforce administrator one
test you know very quickly understand
whether you do or do not have the
appropriate skill gaps and number three
is there are certification bodies out
there the one that I would give you in
digital working such as Oh mcp they
actually will provide a pre-assessment
capability for people to determine
whether they could actually gain a
certification whether that's an om CA
which is an online marketing certified
associate or an online marketing
certified professional so there's my
three hints but I think the most
important thing is most employees know
if they have the requisite skill set
they have to fulfill their career path
goals so I think by going out and
speaking to each employee where they
want to be in two to three years and
seeing where they have self-identified
the largest need for skill acquisition
that's a wonderful approach as well I
really like that last little addendum
that you had There of going to the team
and not just saying I think you're
lacking in this area and I want you to
take this training but tying it to where
they see themselves down the line
they're going to feel so much more
invested in if they get to be a part of
that process that's that sounds really
key all right let's see another question
here for you how do we make time for
training in our team schedules without
impacting their primary tasks negatively
training takes time are you suggesting
that we make training quote-unquote part
of the job on which they get to spend X
percentage of their on the clock time
and if so what would be the appropriate
percentage that I could defend
and that's a great question and of
course each organizational culture is
different when Google used to give 20
designer persons time for them to pursue
their own pet project right because they
knew that that would be a great creative
way to get new ideas inside of Google
but what we're finding is most
organizations the most people and
employees of their time per week is 1.5
three hours so first of all I would
strongly encourage you to look at 1.5
hours as a benchmark the other thing
that we found which has worked really
well to build a culture of continuous
learning in ping baseman is to do things
like lunch and learns so one best
practice we've seen is we actually saw a
team that would get together for lunch
once a week for an hour and a half
people the company would bring in lunch
and they would watch a key learning
video on a specific topic of the week or
topic of the month so they would watch
it together and then after they watched
it they would spend about 15 minutes
actually discussing what they saw and
how could be applied in their department
now you can take that and do it on a
much more structured basis is we've had
one company that took one of our
e-learning courses it was about 12 hours
of video learning and they asked people
to do that for eight weeks one-half
hours in the ninth week they had a
two-hour workshop where they actually
brought in the instructor on the
e-learning video and gave the students
the opportunity to ask him directly hey
on the second week of the video as we
watch this and I get this issue what do
you think how should I approach it so
those are a couple different examples ah
that's that's perfect i really love that
idea of the lunch and learns and you
know if they're
applying what they're learning over the
course of the the weeks to in-house
real-world challenges that affect the
bottom line of the business maybe having
them take a few minutes to to talk about
okay last week we watched video x and
then over the course of the past week
I've been applying these ideas and
here's a success story so that everybody
can see to how not only are they
learning it but they're applying it and
it's positively impacting the company I
like that a lot all right let's see I've
read that tougher training actually
leads to higher completion and retention
rates in other words the harder the
training the more likely they'll finish
that feels counterintuitive can you
speak to that yeah I've not heard that
before no time we experience that well
however I think a parallel that we have
seen is the more academically structured
curriculum is with quizzes
self-assessments a final assessment and
some level of a pipe of based learning
you're going to see much greater
increase competency and retention now
the number one factor weaves me that
leads to completion of a training
program is executive sponsorship with a
real incentive tied to that now we all
just an organization that have mandates
and there's more punitive issues that we
don't complete training we find that the
best and class organizations providing
secure sponsorship incentives to
complete the training
sets and I suspect that when people talk
about tougher training that that
probably means exactly what you're
talking about training that is not just
a sit and watch videos training some
aggregation of a bunch of of streaming
video with no structure but rather
tougher training replies to things like
you know that as you said the quizzes
and the tests to to make it a little
more challenging you know chip there's a
school flat out there today all about
micro learning and micro learning is you
know there's five or ten minutes videos
tips and tricks how to and those serve a
purpose but it really is not going to
lead to increased carbon C and
proficiency on the job I i would agree
given that you know what what experience
I've had as well that the tips and
tricks stuff is is not as rigorous for
lack of a better word perhaps the
analyst yeah when I took differential
equations an engineering school i right
I didn't get it just look at 45 minutes
never be able to apply it right I went
two hours and hours of homework and
hundreds of problem to make sure I could
actually do different general equations
there you know practical applications
that might dovetail into this next
question which is a and you spoke about
this a little bit towards the end of the
presentation but maybe we can put a
finer point on it the comment here is
obviously relapse is a problem for many
training programs learners might cram to
pass certifications but may not actually
retain what they learn what are good
practices for managers to minimize
relapse on their teams after training
well this is where the applied learning
opportunities need to be defined up fun
and apply learning is not just during
the training itself but after the
training
so I'm giving one simple example and one
organization that went through training
everyone had to identify a real-world
project can present what they were going
to do with these skills they actually um
unlearn and if there is an investment
required to do that they also pitch for
the investment can they do that in a
peer review environment and the team
that was viewed as having the best
recommendation actually received funding
to go and apply these new skills in a
real-world project now not everyone's
going to have that luxury but the more
you can pre-plan how are we going to
apply those skills on the job afterwards
that better now with soft skill that's a
little bit harder but with hard skills
if we're going to train 50 people on
Cloudera developer most likely you're
going to have a real-world project that
they're going to apply those skills on
within a month or two very good yeah I
can see how that would you know
definitely keep people's new skills top
of mind and keep them sort of right on
the edge of the the best retention and
really reduce that that relapse issue
let's see here do you have any tips for
incentivising trainees you mentioned in
the presentation incentivization a
little bit and that that works better
than punitive approaches so do you have
experience in working with the clients
that that you've interacted with how how
best to incentivize trainees to to
really make the time and to take the
training seriously well one of the best
approaches is definitely tiny train to
career advancement
you go to this training and exhibit
ability to apply the new skills and
competence on the job that will be a key
criteria for advancement and promotion
so I think nothing Trump's that learning
path equals career path number two there
can be small both financial incentives
or team based incentives such as you
know for a day off if you if you apply
these new skills and deliver this
project on time then you get a hundred
dollars bonus or a day off with team so
I would look at any type of incentives
and rewards program your organization as
outside of career advancement very good
I hope that answered the question for
our our guest here we're about towards
the end of the hour and I know you had a
kind of a wrap up that you wanted to hit
and one of the things I think we should
remind everyone again I think you
mentioned that the slide deck was going
to be available so if that's the case be
sure to let us know how they can get a
hold of that and I'll just say that the
one thing that you said not the one
thing you said a lot of things that I
found really interesting but something
that really struck me was that the
passage where you talked about creating
this pool of most promotable employees
having that key man / succession
planning in place it's just really
interesting to me to think about you
know your people in your team's almost
like a chess game with a long-range plan
for nurturing and involving them into an
optimal team what does your optimal team
look like 24 to 36 months down the line
and how can i use and involve and
nurture the people that i have to get
them there I just I really like that
long-range thinking yes I'll go back to
an aspirational goal for your
organization for every still in a
webinar and this guy struck me at GE and
I still feel so privileged to abet
achieve and we went into this one
training program and the instructors are
looking around
of the four people that you see around
you two of those wat be here in 12
months and we're still investing and
they were this was a kind of a
leadership training so they were
investing about twenty-five thousand
dollars each of us and the company had
so much foresight a to both the value
the training and whether people were
going to be able to apply it achieve
that next level promotion but if we knew
fifty percent of you won't be here in 12
months but we're still going to invest
in you because that's where we're going
to have the employees reducing to be the
best and brightest in the industry so
the one thing I'll leave you with is
making things appear to be so viable and
almost a scarce commodity you're going
to have people clamoring to not only get
trained but to show you how they're
playing that training so trip with that
if there's no more questions I'm going
to find out I'm going to thank everyone
for attending on everyone who did
unregistered attended to the wonders of
marketing automation we will be
receiving an email with a link to this
presentation and you also will be
invited to go to the recorded version of
this if you like to share it with anyone
else within the organization with that
chip thank you very much what if I know
what you are meta all right thank you
Ray for being here and sharing all that
insect very much appreciated for those
of you folks that have stuck out stuck
with us to the end here we sure
appreciate you being here with us take a
look at your chat window really quickly
I just shared a few links with you one
of them is to the upcoming enterprise
webinars page at simply learn the other
one is just in general the upcoming
webinars and resources over on the
simply learn page website in what we
call our career edge section so as you
dig around in there you'll find you can
filter and sort by topic and skill set
and you'll come across a lot of
different articles and white papers and
case studies and upcoming webinars and
all kinds of interesting things there
and lastly if you're interested
a link to the simply learn youtube
channel where you're welcome to
obviously to go over there and take a
look dig around and you'll find some
interesting resources there as well and
I recommend that you subscribe so that
you'll be notified when new videos are
added to the channel I think that takes
us right up to the end of the hour so
thank you everybody for being here and
joining us taking time out of your day
wherever you are whether it was in the
middle of your workday or taking time
out of your personal time in the evening
away from your family to sit down with
us tonight we really really appreciate
you being here and we welcome you the
next time a wrap and until then thanks
everybody take care and we'll see you
next time bye bye thank you
you